j'ai eu un petit peu de soudure avant de
venir je veux juste demandé au fils
qu'elle en pense
géraldine on dirait des rixes et âpre
j'adore ça change
isabelle quoi la chemise la main sur le
tout à semer des déviations tout seul
mon frère mais ça veut dire aller
comment tu vois mal tourner j'aimerais
que vous pourrez la suivre deux balles
de match il a quoi cardiaque hitchock et
ben non parce que moi la chemise j'adore
les lunettes ou un peu moins la couleur
jaune
agathe j'aime beaucoup
[Rires]
je m'étais classique tafia c'est moderne
et chic c'est vrai mais réputé magazine
john dans les couleurs des cocus donc
c'est pas vous mais quoi qu on s'en fout
c'est dès l'âge de 19 ans
tu parlais ma chemise merci agathe très
tendance savourer très bien mais je
presse avait un faible pour les verts
heureusement c'est vrai ouais bah je les
mettrais demain ah non de nommé avec moi
ah oui c'est vrai ça y voir des balles
basses il espère qu'il va pas monter au
filet à prendre la raquette dans la
gueule c'est lui moi j'aime beaucoup le
style bûcheron vintage
il me manque une chaîne en or par contre
j'ai perdu vous savez qu il la manque
baba auprès brune avec plaisir bah vas-y
quand j'aurai ma paye
[Applaudissements]
aga le voulez bien vous ferez votre
chiot nono et pourquoi pas en faire une
chaîne bachand que plusieurs stars comme
barracuda tesla non vous en voulez une
vite vous êtes là impatients de vous en
donner une
non non c'est bon pas
[Applaudissements]